ktla we got to break this one down this
is this is a worrying story they say
san fernando valley residents cast
provisional ballots due to equipment
issue they say some san fernando valley
voters think they are being wrongly
prevented from casting a ballot in the
upcoming gubernatorial recall election
but the county elections office said it
was an equipment issue that was resolved
okay so there's good news right at el
camino real charter high school in
woodland hills some voters say they were
told the computers showed them as
already having voted even though they
had not west hills resident estelle
bender 88 said she was far from the only
person who was being told incorrectly
that they had already voted now for
those that aren't familiar with what's
going on this is the recall election
governor gavin newsom could be removed
and that means whoever is is on the list
who gets the most votes no matter how
many could become the new governor of
california for the next year or so right
now it's looking like that would be
larry elder the polls that have come out
lately show that you know gavin newsom
is doing really really well and he's 16
points up in the 538 aggregate but let
me just tell you
uh the polling was extremely wrong in
basically like the past several
elections going best fo going back five
or so years so i wouldn't rely on that
and more importantly when you see
stories like this and there are many
check out this one we got this one uh
actually this is not that's not the
story i was looking for here's the one
from dave rubin he says holy ish listen
to this as an at an la voting uh voting
center voter quote about 70 percent of
votes this location have been already
shown as cast but they are not election
official right right
this is someone questioning supervisor
vincent mccormick these are from this is
verified twitteries are posting this
video
so people are looking at this stuff
they're thinking something
you know
bad is happening
i'll say this and then we'll jump into
that conversation
don't let it demoralize you for real
right now i see a lot of people saying
things they're sharing these stories
saying like what's the point oh like
there's a point it's go out and vote
because this is a story about a handful
of people and for all you know it was a
glitch that's all it was and they fixed
it and how many people now are like i
give up what's the point that's the
problem you've got to hold the line it's
like that movie i mentioned this earlier
the movie with mel gibson the patriot
when when the british are charging in
and then the militia starts breaking
they're like no and he grabs the flag
and he runs back towards him and he says
hold the line and they do and they win
that's got to do
yeah otherwise gavin newsom wins right
right you don't want that i mean who who
needs several more years of that hair
you know what i mean well he'll get one
more year i suppose but yeah but then
what does even if there is a recall
we'll see i mean i guess if there's if
anything uh you would expect that this
has ruined him for the national stage
because it seems like he was being
primed for it but i would have said the
same thing about uh kamala harris and
her record on on well everything right
like it's awful it's very bizarre how
most of the female candidates at the
federal level that the democrats seem to
push are com have records that are
completely antithetical to their causes
at the time
like think about hillary clinton at the
time
the priorities for the democrats were
getting out of iraq you know uh
women first all this stuff
marriage equality she was against
marriage equality until 2013 when she
got forced into being for it uh she
voted for everything iraq the patriot
act the re the new iraq everything voted
for all that and she spent the late 90s
going after the personal lives of all
the women her husband allegedly sexually
assaulted right so she checked all the
boxes on the other side
she couldn't have been a worse candidate
and then remember the narrative from
that election she's the most single most
qualified candidate in u.s history for
president i believe is what was said are
you kidding me
like she doesn't believe any of the
things that you believe and you're
putting it forward that's i mean it
shows you how completely morally
bankrupt all this stuff really is
youtube's given us the business yeah it
is trying to try to fix it yeah youtubey
yeah i thought uh eisenhower was
was the best
one of the best presidents anyway
about him yeah for sure he was a
military commander so he knew what he
was doing with warriors interstate
highway system he built the interstate
yeah he oversaw the gi bill the va home
loan that built the middle class in the
united states he's responsible for a lot
of stuff right i like that good
president yep
uh this gavin newsom guy's a little a
little awkward the gel in his hair he's
like he's a caricature of all the things
people hate about politicians
like if you're trying to sneak in and be
the new guy on the block and like you
know
uh uh be a professional politician you
at least have to
if you're a wolf you better put the
sheep's clothes on if you show up
dressed like a wolf he's like oh this
guy's a he's a wolf yeah but it's
working for him
that's the shocking yeah you know gavin
newsom looks like
there's a movie
where there's a villain a politician
who's the villain yeah yeah but he's not
like the the main bad guy he's like you
know the secret super villain has bought
a politician and gavin newsom would play
the generic politician sell out
corporate you know corrupt criminal
that's what he looks like yeah but
that's that's kind of you know look you
see the problems california's facing and
you have to wonder what it is the guy
does i know that he puts in absurd
covert restrictions and then violates
them
and uh i know that the state has been in
you know shambles right for some time
now and he's not doing anything about it
he's been really supportive of the
movement towards lawlessness there as
well i mean we were talking about it
earlier about how soros has been
financially invested in all these
attorney general and judge races across
the country over the past six years or
so and all of a sudden he just dumps a
million dollars in the newest recall
campaign that's kind of bizarre right
did he i mean then you have uh gascon in
the in the d.a and in la that are
they're i think they're going to start
paying people to not shoot other people
right you guys yeah that was that was
that in l.a no that wasn't that was in
san fran wasn't it is that portland or
san francisco or somewhere else it's in
california it is in california
yeah they they decided you know what how
about we but the funny thing is like how
do you pay someone not to shoot someone
how does that work how do you
hate me i didn't do
their plan is they're they're they're
going to uh identify people who are
likely to like commit crimes or whatever
so what does that mean they're gonna go
somebody to be like we've determined
that you were probably a low-life
degenerate who would shoot someone so
we're gonna give you money right now and
hope you don't like how do you feel
about that as a criminal are you like
all right cool i'm gonna play the grift
and get the money but it's they were
talking about 300 bucks that's a couple
of transactions if you're a drug dealer
right that's nothing i mean that's and
and they said if you get a job too it's
500 bucks
like don't shoot someone you'll get five
hundred dollars this is you this is real
i guess yes
i got it i got a job and didn't shoot
someone and all i got was this five
hundred dollars i know right i don't
know it seems a little ridiculous
that's that's very bizarre san francisco
yeah san francisco yeah so they're also
paying people 85 grand a year to pick up
human excrement off the ground so you
know what's really funny here's the way
i describe it to people i'm like so you
live in a city right you know where you
you live in a city sir sir yes you have
a fire department
yeah uh yep you have a police department
yep you have uh ems yep do you have a
poop department
i mean there's a department of
sanitation i think that no processes
no no san francisco literally has poo
poop
yeah i mean what about a joke what are
the uniforms like recall this guy i mean
come on
you know in a way i gotta say i don't i
don't know if i can blame the the
governor i don't know if i can blame the
leaders of of overseeing the ship as
it's sinking because we've been on this
course since 1913 if not before that but
it's basically built a ponzi scheme and
now we're seeing it shatter and i don't
care who is in charge of that if they're
going to try and pilot that it's going
to shatter and
so it's like no reason to pariah these
dudes why 1913 federal reserve was
formed right but you i mean do you think
that you really think that was the end
and tell me the coercion of the american
government
the theocratic but i agree with them by
the fascists
yeah like have you ever seen we were
talking about it earlier uh have you
ever seen that uh
canadian sci-fi series uh continuum
you should watch it basically they have
like a corporate congress
so
yeah yeah and it's set in like the late
or i'm sorry it's set in like the early
21st century in seattle i believe but
they're all canadians and
corporations
fund the government more or less and so
they have a say in what what happens and
what doesn't happen right and if
obviously in the future it's a dystopian
nightmare but i feel like right now
the ability of
anyone regardless if it's a corporate
interest to the government to control
what information is and isn't available
right especially these days when it's so
easy to spend a piece of information
that is more powerful than any weapon
you could ever dream of right fourth and
fifth generational warfare you know
what's been going through my head
recently is should i respond to that guy
if someone i like or someone says
something i'm like if i make a response
to them am i going to get flagged and
put on a list
that's
f'd i mean so far i just said aft i
didn't say the word that i normally say
out loud
i am censoring myself at a level i've
never done before well maybe not never
maybe not never because i was in the
entertainment industry right and i want
to say you can't go on like tucker
carlson's show and say a lot
you can say more on this one than you
can say what's disturbing me is just i'm
just not responding to certain people
because i'm afraid it's going to put me
on a list
isn't that crazy are you
crazy i'm sitting here on tim cast irl i
mean i guess that's one way to think
just assume i'm already on the list and
just talk to anyone i want to talk to
but like the way they're tracking social
media and like
persecuting people that were near
the the capitol on
them from their jobs yeah that's weird
that whole i mean i'm sure you guys have
talked exhaustively about the capital
thing but i always wondered and i'm
curious what your audience thinks about
this idea so the united states has what
like on record about 400 million guns
some more guns than people and so it's
the most armed population on earth and
then the most armed subsection of that
population the what they consider to be
the far right
shows up to overthrow the government and
they left all their guns at home yeah
that seems plausible right
i believe that there are people that
exist that are crazy that happen to be
conservative and they're going to do
dumb stuff sometimes and they'll say
they're doing it on behalf of
conservatives the same way people do uh
from the left from religion from
everywhere right
always that there's always that will
always exist and i believe it exists if
you provide me evidence to that effect
in a certain circumstance but when you
tell me that three or four hundred
people show up out of a mass of like 1.3
million people and and they just all
they showed up to overthrow the
government and forgot all their weapons
i don't believe you well they have the
fbi
the fbi said it that's not that's not
true there was no coordinator they were
mad because the way the election they
thought the election was going with the
voting so they wanted to show power they
wanted to feel like they had some sort
of power ian why don't you put in a
foyer
file a foia request
for your name
and see what comes up
i thought about it but it's like just do
i want to dig up that wormhole man
i'm down i would like i guess i could
see it i don't want to make myself more
paranoid than i needed to quote you a
bunch of times on this show probably
yeah i bet mine's massive you know
everyone here i'm sure a lot of people
who watch actually might have something
well the ss the splc has weighed in on
you a number of times right there was
like two two things and one got
retracted with an apology because they
they claimed that uh
a holocaust denying
archive of a website that i had gone to
iran for a holocaust denying conference
which is like one of the most insane
crackpot things you can ever publish and
so they were forced to take that down
issue or attraction an apology because
i've never been to iran that's just plum
nuts well bill maher
and uh religious have you seen that
looks like a documentary religious
religious yeah yeah so he he went to
this uh area and visited with a jewish
rabbi who is a holocaust denier so as he
on a list is bill maher on the list for
interviewing people that he finds yeah
but even if you went to something like
that to cover it that doesn't that is
what journalism is supposed to be right
well no this website claimed i was like
a speaker oh boy and it's just like it's
just crackpot nonsense it's like dude if
some weirdo puts my name on a website
you believe it's true that so they had
to take it down and apologize the the
the splc is is immaterial it's it's oh
yeah yeah they're not the people who
spend their time worried look i get a
lot of smear pieces written about me all
the time and you know the most annoying
thing in the world is is when someone
sends me it and i'm like first of all
you think i don't know second of all why
should i read it or care
like literally it's not affecting me in
any way
it's there's zero impact on my business
it's just a waste of time from from from
whiny you know stupid babies who i don't
care about it is uh
your time is certainly better spent
doing other things and the people it's a
distraction they try they try and wrap
you up and catch up and the stuff and
and you know what uh um to segue right
back and what we're talking about it's
demoralizing it is yeah if you spend all
your day looking at the people saying
mean things about you it's distracting
you from doing good work they're they're
snaring you in that trap ignore it i i
would say getting involved in these uh
in the weeds conversations about what is
and isn't uh we were talking about this
earlier uh people
people are spending a lot of time
debating what communism and socialism
and fascism is
why don't we just
call it what it is it's authoritarianism
it doesn't matter where it comes from if
your house is on fire you're not sitting
there like i wonder how my house caught
on fire no you're grabbing buckets of
water and trying to put the fire out
right man you know it's going to take a
collective effort to do that and i
really i understand that tempers run hot
and all this stuff and people are afraid
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast if you want to
see the full show come back to this
channel youtube.com tim cast irl monday
through friday at 8 pm where you can
leave comments and super chat and we
actually will read your comments on the
show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time
you